shaq congratulations uh a brilliant day
for you at the office describe to us our
your initial feelings right now
okay
but i can say i just play chess
uh normally
normally in classical chess i just try
to play interesting chess and try to get
interesting position from opening but
now is from first movies interesting
position
much better to play this
chess i mean i just play and
what i can say just good games
given that you're such a creative uh
genius do you feel like this chess 960
helps you gives you an edge over your
opposition given that there's no theory
okay i mean
of course uh normally i like to play
this chess and uh i think zoom
for me is very interesting but i don't
think
it will be
very good to play many tournaments in
this
960 because
because in our days it's not easy play
normal chess
how we can play in classical and
rapid beliefs also in the 960. but i
love this to play this
chairs and i had good results i mean
i because i enjoyed from
first move to try to sing everything
and
for this reason
i
just happy to play in this yes levon
said something very interesting
yesterday he said that in chess 960 with
the black pieces you can actually be
much better after five moves of play
definitely felt it was the case in this
game between yourself and nepo take us
through the game okay i mean first of
all i want to say leon's absurd right
because i played here in four games and
i won all four games with black
only i mean i played in with white not
very good i mean just 50 prospects but i
with black in the really every game in
with black i mean against
yesterday today against jan i think
against hikaru and after move five every
time i got minus three why do you feel
that's the case yeah it's just i think
also same for me i when i played with
white against fabiano i just
got a very bad position from openings
because uh normally we think like
classical chess we need to get advantage
we need to play for win without yeah
with white of course you need to play
for active win but for this reason it's
absolutely different i mean in in this
just you need to play just good moves i
mean normal moves not try to win in in
few moves
because it's upset another strategical
level he played very well this
1960
but
[Music]
for me is upset
different again i i don't know
absolutely good rulers how to do castle
sometimes i ask i ask i see when my
arbiter is near me i watch his aces i
can do it
he will say play with king and he's
playing i need to resign but i don't
know it's for sure not a one-handed
project because
it was one very funny
story i played in mainz
in 1960 i played i was in leading in
tournament in last game i played against
grishok but all piece it was same same
in classical chess only
rook in a1 in knight b1 is different
knight a1 and rook b1
yeah and i tried to play d4 is
d5 c4 c6 knight f36 e3 f5 i mean he
played classical chess and i i tried to
b3 bishop b2 bishop a3 change this
bishop he b3 he played queen seven
defense i played bishop b two quincy one
bishop e3 i mean i mean i just play
bishop e3 and he taking my bishop and
this is not in 19b1 and rook and i
resign in my serious more most important
game in my i mean 1960s because it
wasn't my i was in first place it was
draw for me it's okay for first place
and i lose this game in eight moves i
mean sometimes we could forget about
yeah let's talk about this position
particularly because we saw it on the
camera and it felt like you are enjoying
yourself at this point were you feeling
well normally we all resign in these
positions of course better especially
when he played a little bit i am very
tired yeah he take look at four i start
to calculate e1 queen maybe bishop b7 he
tried to play check one more check okay
i will take king and i like them okay i
am little bit tight and i want to go
restaurant
yeah i think it's better one night yeah
it's just
to win with check i bet of course i
remember this very famous game against
hikaru in paris he got he played g one
night and he lose me it's inside the g1
queen yeah i mean sometimes it is it can
be very bad i mean you can play
very nice you want to play just easy
move but after you see it it's very bad
but now the king cannot how is now is
king c193 is made kings
very nice amazing
congratulations uh brilliant day at the
office for you we're looking forward to
see you in the last day thank you